is social security really a Ponzi scheme
this week I call the SEC and find out so
there's been a lot of hoopla lately
surrounding Social Security hoopla
leftists accuse those of calling it a
Ponzi scheme is nothing more than
radical extremists even though Andrew
Biggs the former Social Security Deputy
Commissioner said that the two are
virtually identical except that Social
Security is involuntary but what does
the government consider to be a Ponzi
scheme well thanks to Eric Erickson and
red-state I recently came across the
sec.gov very own definition a Ponzi
scheme is an investment fraud that
involves a payment of reported returns
to existing investors from funds
contributed by new investors Ponzi
scheme organizers often solicit new
investors by promising to invest funds
and opportunities claimed to generate
high returns with little to no risk and
many Ponzi schemes the fraudsters focus
on attracting new money to make promised
payments to earlier stage investors and
to use for personal expenses instead of
engaging in any legitimate investment
activity they are literally describing
social security exactly by the year 2016
according to Social Security trustee
estimates the benefits paid out by
Social Security will exceed that of
taxes collected and the numbers are only
projected to get worse as a number of
retirees per taxable workers are
increasing dramatically when the scheme
was founded there were over 40 workers
per retiree we're now down to a ratio of
3 to one and it's expected to go to 2 to
1 in the not-too-distant future
and so you and I are forced into a
system to pay out previous investors and
when the system inevitably collapses
we're left holding the bag folks I'm not
sure that the SEC knows about this
social security thing thank God they
list a phone number on their website 807
3 2 0 3 3 0 where we can all flag
potential Ponzi schemes and I did so
were you the one who called me earlier
yeah okay well thank you sorry about
that it's just been a crazy busy day and
I know your folks can be hard to get
ahold of I was doing some research he
was on the SCC gov website doing a
little bit of research on on Ponzi
schemes and looking at your definition
and I can't be sure but where
work basically there's this investment
opportunity where they pretty much
promise no risk which I can't imagine
and it seems to be when I run the
numbers that the only people who could
possibly benefit would be the initial
investors and I've gotten in this thing
a little bit late so I'm a little bit
scared that I may be you know holding
the bag on this deal because it doesn't
seem like I could get any return at all
does that sound like from your website
does that sound like something that
could be a Ponzi scheme I'm sure you can
imagine you know my concern with Madoff
and things like that you know obviously
it's a sort of in the public eye right
now and then you know I can't withdraw
anything at all so I can't I can't
receive any payments or withdraw any
payments I don't really have any way to
get out of it and the numbers just just
don't seem to add up it seems like it
can't possibly work return no they're
basically pulling the money from people
yet and then and then promising a rate
of return after a certain amount of time
but the rate of return seems to be the
same it's never changed even after the
you know the downturn economy which is
what's seen to raise some red flags that
I can't imagine you know returns it
would be that consistent especially as
more people get in which seems to be the
case they keep you know every time I
hear about it I get any kind of
newsletter about it it basically says
well it'll work as long as we get
so-and-so amount of people in it and it
seems to be an increasing number for it
to work you know we obviously we can't
advise you if you think they're doing
something improper and putting you know
your money at risk where they're not a
legitimate company
then one thing you can do is obviously
provide us with that information in
writing is them then you know if you put
everything in writing first of all you'd
be eligible for the word
depending on what happens but that way
you know we can kind of systematically
look at it and determine whether there
is something there that should be
investigated possible violations of the
securities laws well it's not a company
it's not really a company that's that's
the thing it's taken out of my paycheck
it's um some of your under Oh Oh as d of
your paycheck where does that let me go
I have the acronym euro as D the the
original Social Security Act of 1935
okay now it should be noted that as a
beacon of government efficiency my phone
call was rerouted for 20 minutes before
I was finally able to leave a message
and they issued that return call so
during that time I also filled out the
form at sec gov I warned them about this
Ponzi scheme and you should to either
call the SEC at eight hundred seventy
three two zero three three zero that's
eight hundred seven three two zero three
three zero or email them at SEC gov I've
made it easy for you I put the link in
the sidebar not only should you do it
but send this video to everybody you
know so that they can do it too because
I genuinely don't think the SEC knows
about this Ponzi scheme folks and you
should let them know because knowledge
is power
you